[Music]
did you guys know there's a chinese tea
that costs
184 000 per kilogram it's good [ __ ]
that's more than cocaine baby
what does it do to your dick oh is it a
satisfaction is it a strain of high
mountain tea i don't know what the
height mountain is expensive i bet it's
from like a tree that's a thousand years
old or something on a very very peak at
a mountain is there like opium in it
well birds uh birds good questions all
right i'll just i'll just let you guys
know right so um the waiter comes up to
you at this when you're at this you know
establishment fine establishment yeah
they come up and they go hey uh
would you you like to have a sniff
and so they bring a sniff people don't
say sniff they do a whiff sniff it's
right here on cnn travel you [ __ ]
idiot yeah
please have a sniff and he says with the
cognac glass you can get more of the
fruit smell with the burgundy burgundy
glass you get more of the floral flavors
the glasses changes the aroma of course
they do you've ever hung out with a wine
snob before no no i talked about it i
had no idea i always thought that was
[ __ ] it's real i think it is red
[ __ ] am i right go ahead and sip
take a sip we need to get a sponsorship
you guys drink so much red bull here hey
look
you know what we're just doing what we
can we're doing stream content too yeah
dude we're pretty extreme
i like their instagram page though we
like chicken wings and rebel gives you
wings we do extreme words all right so
back to this tea yeah so the most prized
item at this at this um establishment is
called the knee
the knee mom
thank you well it's like i did it cool
uh
it is it's a rare variety of rogue
rogue tea i don't [ __ ] know from a
valley brook of the same name in the
woody mountains all right deal with it
mountains just mountains yeah sounds
like some little ring [ __ ] right
the retail price is
4560 for 25 grams
184 gs for a kilogram at the time of
writing so you can enjoy a brew of the
tea
at the restaurant which costs you like
thirty five hundred dollars
thirty five hundred for a pot of tea
it's a racket
what the [ __ ] does this do look rare
teas have been commanding huge time
dollars in china right it's not a new
trend apparently in 2002 20 grams of
don
also a mountain tea once preserved for
the emperor's lips only so he's the only
cat who ever got to drink this [ __ ] was
auctioned for 28 000
in a place called
guangatsu or some [ __ ]
in 2009 a 100 gram typing hooky god damn
it okay a green tea from another place
whatever
this auction for for 200 000 dollars
like for their currency
thank you for all this info you need
more names and places listen to me
okay so you have to wear a [ __ ] i
don't know what that is
and you have to say i don't know how to
say it
if you want to order it no no that's not
in here okay so uh so yeah look all this
is like very bougie stuff right it's
like if you go here this is like on the
special menu you got to be the person
who's like i want the douchey thing and
they're like oh
but yeah no this is all about you know
having the rare experience that not a
lot of people get to have so i think
that there are um
certain thresholds for when something is
absolutely ridiculous and not worth it i
think a 3 500 pot of tea is
past that threshold well we need to get
our buddy stephen lim here okay where he
is the creator of worth it where he
tests
a [ __ ] two cent bag of tea
and a hundred fifty thousand dollar bag
of tea some lip tint how much better
could it be said bag of tea you're so
like politically correct why tea bag
would have been funnier yeah the teabag
is way better what time is right there
missed opportunity oh by the way tea
bags
missed opportunity that's what a college
dude puts his balls on your face and
then he's like haha you got tea bag
that's never happened to me i don't
think i i really got the college
experience oh dude hey ryan huckleberg
real quick nah i mean
it's past my time have you ever played
halo before i got t better yeah you get
teabagged a lot lately but that happens
when you sleep
when you're sleeping like
and then someone goes deep
dip your balls in his mouth do they have
to stutter that much yeah but you have
to be drunk sleep because if you're just
regular sleep you might like bite oh god
but you know what we did do when our
buddy was drunk and he knocked out we we
made a full-on
and then tuxedo just goes alice [ __ ]
make him the monopoly
and then we just
got his shirt off so he just made a
whole tuxedo did you give him a monocle
hell yeah
that was good this is the most you guys
would pay for some stupid [ __ ] thing
not that much
i paid a lot of money for some stupid
[ __ ] well bart you have a legendary like
you know you're like my postmates bill
is like whoa
it's not like that maybe the most
expensive thing that i was like oh man
that's pretty crazy was maybe i spent
almost a thousand bucks on um
on the conor mcgregor khabib fight you
probably spent more than that that was
like
[ __ ] nosebleeds for a thousand bucks
i spent 20 grand on the tea room in my
old office i spent 10 thousand dollars
on a picture of a monkey
oh yeah you did you got a board aside it
wasn't five thousand dollars on an nfc
dragon egg
hope it works out you you you really
spent 25 grand on one now but at the
time it was like 12 but then luna did so
well it's unfortunate and it sucks oh
it's value that you didn't spend that
much it's valued now
i spent 10 grand on a picture of a
monkey and the value went down i spent
it on a moment though i don't have any
it's just oh you [ __ ] idiot you
didn't get a jpeg out of it
dude
it was just air
i don't have nothing i spent 500 i think
550 bucks just on sims 3 content
as he sips again dude every single time
he [ __ ] hits it
so good technique he throws really
[ __ ] good wow so i said earlier he's
like he's like oh you guys are doing
some [ __ ] oh cool what are you guys
buying how cool and then like five
minutes later he's like yeah i got some
and then sips
i wouldn't call that a waste either yeah
i spent like 20 something
a thousand on a car that's old oh yeah
the jeep right or the um thank cruiser
279 000 miles
yeah that's appreciating though i spent
like 500 bucks on three lap dances once
wow
hey what's an uncomfortable amount of
lap dances for a guy who's on a bachelor
party an uncomfortable amount for the
bachelor yeah
depends on the guy more than five
what's normal what's a normal amount
how long do lab dances last one song 97
and the song the song is shorter than
the like
the real song they're playing at like 2x
speed yeah
it only goes to leave out they leave out
the bridge just the react just the
bridge it's like a commercial yeah it's
intro versus hook bridge last hook
what's your highest bar tab you've ever
had i don't drink 800 something dollars
800. wait how do you have a big bar tag
we don't drink buying for other people
yeah you're not sober drunk he's the
leader of quest crew so he has to do
that i understand what are you drinking
cherry seven up well as a member of
quest crew
that's true we built a whole bar for you
guys and we don't even drink that
alcohol uh we drink it religiously yeah
me and him i'll have a coke from there
every now and then you know just a glass
of coke and sometimes we have a guest
who maybe does but i enjoy the ice cubes
awesome bart thank you it's free
um so yeah no but i was at a at a
bachelor party right and this cat gets
like it was it was weird because i and i
like him and i like his chick too but
this cat had like
15 laptops 15. double digits is
available yeah double digits is too much
that sounds like
deprived he was binging
girl like multiple times you know what
though it was same girl a couple times
but you know though i feel like lap
dancers are like i like crypto in the
sense that like some people
who are like in an early game have so
much wealth that their wealth concept is
different so the idea of like spending
like a million dollars on a picture of
something you're like damn you spend a
million dollars but for them they maybe
got all those ethernet staking roads
rich ass people go to the strip club and
they spend like thousands of dollars to
like not get anything but to like have a
conversation with the chick in the back
room because they can so 10 lap dances
is nothing that's like so i think it
depends on the person it's like when
people come to my crypto corner like oh
i have to spend eight dollars in fees
and we're all just like
just [ __ ] who cares
just [ __ ] just pay the money for the
[ __ ] are you talking i look i get it yes
bg it's great i love being cheap it's
awesome
it's eight dollars who gives a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you talking about you're not
talking about me right no you oh you
complained about like 800 maybe now you
should because you're just three lap
chances you used to complain about
cheaper things dances 800 bucks no no
that's like seven
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you